hey guys this is dennis the founder fake
here and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and we
just came back from comic-con and a lot
of big news and stuff so one of the big
things that came out was the whole
Avengers 2 announcement got a title now
yes now I have to be honest I was kind
of disappointed I don't know if some of
you guys know I also work for AMC
theatres I was there shooting for them
we're at the press line and you know it
already heard the big announcement from
from WB about Superman vs Batman which
we talked about in another video but so
after that happened Marvel was after and
there was kind of like a hype thing like
where we thought like wow Marvel's gonna
like do something big you know by their
announced ant-man and Nathan feelings
gonna play ant-man or something crazy
like that but then when all said with
all that was said and done it was just
the title you know we find out who
Benicio played the collector and stuff
like that but but it wasn't the the big
like reveal that we thought it was gonna
be and after you know Batman vs Superman
it was kind of a letdown oh right what
do you know what do you think about this
whole agit Ron title and I mean it does
give us direction of where they're going
yeah it does i feel like avengers 2 i
have a lot of faith in nothing's good
you know it's Josh Wheaton writing again
I think it's gonna be solid I do think
though it is gonna be like lord of the
rings two towers I think it's going to
be a bridge we now know that gardens of
the galaxy is going to point to Thanos
so we're going to have a nose in that
movie where this is going to be Ultron
and talents is going to be more a part
of phase three okay I learnt phase two
which I'm fine with just an Ultron
unless you read comic book there's no a
lot of you to Washington's do you read
complex you're familiar watch the
cartoons as a kid you know the
characters but the thing is I mean it's
like Ultron's not that significant I
mean they just did the age of Ultron
story Brian Michael Bendis to the story
on it this year in 2013 10 ish you make
sure you can check a limited search you
can check it out but I don't know the
character himself i mean we learned
though in the news that mark that Pym
ant-man is not going to be a part of the
creation of Ultron
ours we know in Avengers 2 that was
confirmed as ugly and said that he
wasn't part of it right to so there you
know we're suming there's been a lot of
speculation that that it's gonna be Tony
Stark instead yeah creates Ultron right
yeah Ultron's not like a super popular
super well-known right villain everyone
assumed that Thanos yeah at the end of
Avengers if you saw the you know the
post-credit see famous and then and you
think okay he's that's who the villains
gonna be for ventures to and you know
the Holy Infinity Gauntlet thing and all
that so I thought all of phase two is
gonna lead up to that but apparently
they're gonna drag that out to phase
they're already planning for Avengers 3
whatever the next iron man's gonna be
whatever that looks like a Tony Stark
surf road right here is even gonna be a
part we know you signed on for Avengers
2 + + + 3 but we don't know he's never
confirmed for a bit first Ironman for
whatever yeah I don't think he's going
to program rebooted I don't think
they're gonna have an iron man they're
definitely not having iron man and face
three right so no they're gonna do their
phase 2 stuff Terry are still in the
process in iron man through as part of
that so phase 3 I think they're skip
over and i right yeah i don't know what
they're gonna do after so we do know
that we do know this though we know Thor
and Captain America will point to to
Ultron whereas like I said Garza got
your point to the tadano so it's good i
mean it is ultra I mean he's like one of
those super intelligent beans I mean he
was created as I said 1968 i think it
was Avengers issue number 54 number 55
he came in the late 60s you know he you
know obtained into a got intelligence
he's artificial one of those kind of
things like he gets awareness and then
doesn't like what he see so in age of
Ultron the new store I'm not gonna tell
you the whole story josh meeting today
they're gonna view you know go sku a
little bit away from the story so what
he does is he comes in and he's just
basically tries to remake humanity in
his own image in a sense it's kind of
interesting story I'm not one of my
favorites but you know I just waiting
they're gonna tweak things it's not
gonna be exact copy of so if you read
the comic book and I can be seen oil you
know that little tweak things no I it's
not that I'm you know I have faith in
joss whedon I'm faith in in Marvel and
so I'm expecting great things I'm just
saying the reveal it
alpha comma cries a bit yeah wonder why
yeah I think thing that honestly a
comic-con is hard marble with data was
the most thrilling is low key you know
that as yeah only hallways Loki's Hall H
just you know go check it out on youtube
watch the video like just him doing his
thing and just kind of being lowkey like
the crowd is when not yeah Tom Nelson
dressed up as Loki went all age I
pretended you know he's like you guys
bow down to me and Bobby say my name say
my name is a lot of one you know so I
thought that was really cool but he was
the only person from Thor to that was
yeah cuz I'll go nowhere around yeah so
yeah the things as a little funny
because you were actually on the press
line doing this I mean I'm not trying to
criticize the actors they're tired I'm
it all drive you know traveling from
London that night for gardens the galaxy
panel but literally only they're all
really know what's going on yet like
Benicio is just kind of like you know he
hasn't shot benicia has right any prize
everyone's yeah yeah was hard for them I
think to show enthusiasm like they're
like this is like yeah i saw i just saw
the clip like wow even though it's like
you know you're playing and so the
collector yeah i know nothing about you
know guys the galaxy's week that's not
an area i'm strong in but there's new
gardens of galaxy series going on at
Marvel the whole Marvel now thing
there's Quantico reboot like that's
going on right now so you can read that
to cut you know to get your cards the
galaxy knowledge up but um I mean I do
appreciate Marvel kind of using some of
the obscure characters I'm just curious
to see how they're gonna develop their
story it's always about story everything
about story so I'll be curious to see
what Joss Whedon and company do yeah I
just thought there would be more like a
black panther announcement but alright
well let us know what you guys thought
of the news of Avengers tues title were
you kind of disappointed were you happy
about it i mean what about Ultron is a
villain do you think that's a good move
and are you disappointed that that
dannis is gonna be it's a good way yeah
while like he's probably gonna keep his
head in guardians of gallons and set up
maybe Thor to do a third Thor maybe he
might show up a little bit then build up
to Avenger that's gonna be 56 who knows
how long it's gonna be I'll be waiting a
while alright guys so make sure you post
your comments below on the website or on
this YouTube video make sure you
subscribe to our
youtube channel it's a think hero pro
and you can follow us on twitter minds
at think hero i'm at griffin de and we
have some a facebook page that's a
facebook.com slash think hero fans